ايام اخرى عصيبه يعيشها ملايين الامريكيين
طبعا مع استمرار العاصفه الثلجيه القاسيه
التي خلفت خسائر كبيره في الارواح عاصفه
شتويه خلفت 46 قتيلا على الاقل في انحاء
البلاد وبينما لا يزال السكان في غرب
نيويورك محاصرين تحت اقدام من الثلوج لم
تعد اجهزه الطوارئ قادره على التعامل مع
الظروف الصعبه الناجمه عن السقيع الناجم
عن العاصفه الثلجيه وايضا انخفاض درجات
الحراره
[موسيقى]
اطفال
هناك
المزيد من الارقام الخاصه
بالاضافه الى هذه التصريحات اكد مفاوض على
اشغال العامه في مدينه بافلوبي نيويورك
اكد بان التركيز الان يتجه نحو الحفاظ على
سلامه الارواح بعدما كان ينصب على تامين
المتاجر طبعا للوصول الى الغذاء تصريحات
تشير الى ان هذه العاصفه هي الاكثر تدميرا
في تاريخ بافلوا الطويل حيث ادى تساقط
الثلوج الى جعل الطرق غير سالكه طبعا مع
انعدام الرؤيا ارتفع عدد الوفيات المؤكده
والمرتبطه بالعواصف الثلجيه في تلك
المنطقه الى 25 حاله وفاه
نتحدث عن الحياه والامان وكيفيه الوصول
الى شخص عالق كما تعلمون الطعام من عناصر
الحياه والامان لكن الان ينصب تركيزنا على
الحياه والسلامه فقط
وفقا شبكه سي ان ان العاصفه الشتويه تسببت
في دفن اجزاء من غرب نيويورك بما يصل الى
43 بوصه من الثلوج مما ترك المركبات عالقه
وادى الى انقطاع التيار الكهربائي وذلك
للالاف وفي احدى مقاطعه ولايه نيويورك
ابلغ المسؤولون عن ثلاثه حاله وفاه اضافيه
طبعا بسبب العاصفه الثلجيه الكارثيه
واشنطن بوست من جهتها اكد بان العاصفه
الثلجيه تسببت في تجمد محطات الكهرباء
الفرعيه وايضا اغلاق بعض الطرقات البلاد
الاكثر انشغالا طبعا مع فتره اعياد
الميلاد الصحيفه اشارت الى ان اكثر من 10
ملايين شخص كانوا تحت انذارات التجميد
وذلك في جميع الب بما في ذلك سكان
اورلاندو ومونتميكرو وبيراميدز
[موسيقى]